hi and welcome to episode number 22 of
the weekly Google apart from podcast I'm
Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
friends ask how you doing today pretty
good very very excited about our
interviews with an s interviews can s
very sneaky we're sneaking in an extra
interview extra interview today so we're
gonna we're gonna have for our cool
thing of the week it's going to be an
interview and then our main Compton is
going to be an interview and then for
the question of the week it will not be
an interview now happy no no no yeah so
we're gonna have for our main content of
the week we're gonna be talking with ray
1 yep you talk to her about I am yep and
then at the end we're going to be
talking about something quite cool which
is about how do you pronounce it caching
caching caching yeah that's wrong so
yeah we're gonna be talking about
cashing in what you can do there's some
cool stuff going on so but before that
we have our coping of the week yeah
we're going to be talking to Brendan
Byrnes lead engineer on the Koopa
Neely's project we met up with him at
gcp necks and had a really great
conversation with him yep he gave a I
think he gave a talk no he did not give
it out but he was around and we decided
to interview him and we have it it's a
pretty short interview so we decided
that it could be a very cool thing of
the week definitely let's get to it so
hi Brendan Brendan Byrnes how are you
doing hi doing great so for those that
don't know who Brendan Byrnes is he's
the famous person that made the made a
video about what is faster to start gke
content or to make a latte that's true
actually and it's gotten faster so I'm
gonna have to up my latte making game it
yeah that is pretty awesome so tell us a
little bit about yourself who are you
what do you do like Google sure so I've
done a lot of things ago I've been at
Google almost eight years but in the
Google cloud platform what I've done
recently is I have with a couple of
co-collaborators a couple years ago had
this crazy idea that maybe we should
open source some of our ideas and
cluster management the Borg software
that runs everything from search to
gmail and everything and actually all of
the VMS and everything that Google
platform runs who should build out an
open source version of that software and
we started doing that it came out a
little under two years ago as a project
called Cooper Nettie's and it's grown
from there and so we just keep trying to
push that forward and help everybody
sort of compute like Google does whether
they actually honestly whether they're
on the Google cloud platform or not yeah
so really believe that we want it to go
you know into people's data centers as
well as being available in the Google
cloud wherever they happen to be running
their computer yeah we actually had some
cool demos about it today we interviewed
Kelsey Hightower two weeks ago or so
about Cuban eighties one that you could
you tell us a little bit about what's
your favorite feature Frankie Renee's
wonder too if you had to choose one if I
have to choose one I mean it's like your
children like that supposed to choose
you know I choose your favorite your
favorite children they're not listening
now are there not nesting yeah I don't
know the features have ears um what am i
what is my favorite feature well I mean
I'm really happy to see things a couple
of things go go GA right so I'm really
happy to see the work on things like
auto scaling and stuff like that go to
get to a place where it's it's done
right I mean well maybe nothing
everything nothing is actually done but
to the point where we really say this is
reliable this is production grade you
can go out and do it I you know I think
it's important to introduce new features
you know I'm excited to see things like
the daemon set and the config map I'll
talk a little bit more about those it's
important to introduce new features but
it's also important to make sure that
things move through that like beta
production ready ready out there and
people can use it kind of cycle because
it shows that we're not just start
throwing new ideas out there we're
actually finishing off the ideas that we
have so I'm a really excited to see that
happen I'm actually really excited at
config map is one of those things I'm
really excited about config is a big
important problem for people doing
distributed systems and so I'm excited
to see that happen and I'm also excited
because you know it's an example of
something that was largely built by
people outside of Google all right and
and so that was always the promise of
open source was the community and
community development and engaging with
with people who are using it and so it's
really nice
that as well all right it's a great
feature for everybody but it's a great
feature that google didn't build
excellent of course now i need to ask
what exciting things do you think you're
going to see in the future so what I was
just working on the on on the plane on
the way down which is most of the way in
but does not didn't quite make it into
one dot to is the idea of third-party
extensions to the API and so what this
basically allows you to do your cluster
is introduce your own API types right so
you can you without recompiling it
without doing anything you can walk up
to the cluster you can say I have this
new great object called of food and I
want to you know I want to start
managing a foo I don't really want to
worry about storage I don't want to
really worry about optimistic
concurrency and and if multiple of
people update something at the same time
I don't want to have to do any of that
logic but I have this new kind of food
that I wanted that I want to manage and
so you create a resource you know foo
resource on the server and suddenly you
have this new resource type that you can
play around with it works with all our
command line tooling that works with all
our client libraries I'm pretty excited
about that because I think that's going
to unlock people building Cooper
Nettie's plugins right we're not we're
in a world right now where if you as a
vendor or you as a third party or even
inside of Google if you want to deploy
something inside of Cooper Nettie's you
have to land it in our code base you
have to get it committed you have to go
through our code review process you have
to you know how to eat like you have to
do all of this stuff and then we kind of
have to maintain it and it so it's
awkward on both sides right it's awkward
for the owner who really they want to
own that thing independently and it's
awkward for us because we have to you
know when we change something we've got
to fix your code even though we might
not actually understand your code that
will ya and so really excited cuz i
think it's going to enable a lot more
rapid development and a lot more
distribution of ownership that's going
to make the project even more scalable
than it already is so that's that's
really the thing that I'm I'm most
excited about for 13 uber Nettie's is
another thing that I think is pretty
awesome there's going to be some talk
and discussion about that here as well I
think and that's basically enabling you
to manage multiple clusters as I sort of
taking a global view on your cluster
footprint instead of an individual data
center view so I'm pretty excited about
that as well no I've definitely been
speaking to a lot of people who want to
have that cross region or plus cloud or
boss like different data center time
management solutions is very excited
about your new yeah that's one of those
ones where I was like can you at least
let us get done with what we started and
we were like here it's this awesome
thing and then everyone's like but what
if I have to and we won't like once it's
done yeah I could have you're ready to
take want to go to the next thing so
it's great to see that start starting to
happen as well yet again that's a great
example you know Google's doing a lot of
work there Quinn who is doing a lot of
work there but huawei the Chinese
telecom company is also heavily involved
in that process so again it's really
nice to see that community coming
together very nice so we know you're
here to speak at ease be next so what
are you gonna be talking about you know
we're mostly going to be talking about 1
dot to the gym yeah so like people some
people are at cube cond I think cube con
is kind of a little bit more first of
all was in Europe yeah and so I actually
didn't get to travel his family and all
that um and I think that's more of a
cooper Nettie's audience not necessarily
a full general cloud audience and so i
think here we're really going to try and
highlight you know uh urban Nettie's for
people who haven't seen it before
container engine for people haven't seen
far not too much on that because I think
we've mostly gone over that hurdle yeah
but then a lot about like what is the
stuff that we're we've introduced what
how does it make building distributed
systems easier because at the end of the
day that's what we're really about it's
like let's build reliable distributed
systems in an easier way yeah that's all
that sounds like a great talk uh were
you here on time to what's to follow the
keynote I followed the keynote on
Twitter on the plane on the way down and
actually get a chance to be here what
was your favorite announcement what did
you but what did you get the most
excited about well I mean I'm pretty
excited to see that the damn of them
sort of two plus plus the demo that i
did so i did this demo at q con o in
december right i did this 1,000,000 QPS
demo so for kelsey and and other folks
to take that and like really take it to
the next level you know I that was
really awesome I adds a little bit
self-centered i guess but took you know
i think that was an awesome demo i
thought i'd be awesome so I'm hoping
that generate some buzz um not a demo
that was on the stage this morning but
another announcement that went out this
morning that I thought was pretty
awesome as well was tensorflow which is
the open-source machine learning
algorithm that we've the I shouldn't say
we but that folks at Google have
released on they just put out
instructions for running a distributed
version of that on top of Cooper
Nettie's so doing image recognition all
the way out in the open you don't need
any you know you do it on your own stack
of computers so that went out on the
Cuban latest blog post this morning very
excited to see that land I didn't know
about that will definitely i know it's
awesome i'm really i'm definitely
excited to see it they do some image
recognition stuff that's pretty cool so
and do those two those guys have you had
a chance to kind of wander around and
have a play with any the playground
things here no you know i i'm not i just
came in the door so I'm gonna just go to
your own zine oh yeah like I walked
right by and you grabbed me so now I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a chance to look at
I saw some old video games over there I
might have to go check out the tetris
the tetris thing there it is incredibly
lots of fun oh I would imagine though
it's in a while since I played Tetris I
see two I see Kelsey doing that demo but
yeah it's been a while since I played
Tetris so I'm excited to give that a
give that a whirl so very good well
thanks so much for talking to us no
problem at all and she lets for having
me see you later thanks up so that was a
great conversation that we had with
Brendan at gcb next I actually really
enjoy going back to listen to the
highlights and some interviews we have
from GSP next it was a really great
event yeah we still have a bunch of them
so maybe improve next episodes will will
add some key pls minik some of those
interviews in there definitely yeah
actually before before we go with the
main Compton there's also if you thought
that this interview was interesting you
should definitely check our episode
number 16 that we have with Kelsey
Hightower also the topic of Cuba night
is one the two and all the things that
we that we really so make sure you check
it out definitely it was also a really
interesting conversation so why don't we
go to our main content of the week I
just renamed that section right now so
we're gonna be talking to Ray one
excellent when we have a chat with her
today we are joined by ray Wang to talk
to us about I am how are you doing today
right I'm doing great thank you so why
don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself first okay um hi I'm ray
a product manager working on Google
cloud platform I look after the IM part
of gcp I'm basting the Google Seattle
office and helping at Google for three
years before that I worked in other
software companies for over a decade
very cool and could you tell us a little
bit about what is exactly I am you said
yes i am at three letters instance for
identity and access management well if
your security guru you might say it
means authentication and authorization
what it basically is is these two parts
the the eye part in the I am part the
eye part also is means authentication
it's how you define the identity of a
user or program and then be able to
verify the identity you know you are who
you say you are waiting trying to access
gcp resources and they have the am part
which is access management and that's
your access policies other relation it's
where your define who can do what which
resources so then we put two parts
together they safeguard your google
cloud resources and they make sure that
only people that you want them to access
certain part of gcp can assess the
specific resources that they allow to
access so you mentioned resources and
number of time what is resources mean is
that just like parts of the console or
is that mean actual things that are
running in the cloud what is that what
does it refer to well a research the
most basic level is a thing you can you
can use in cloud for example a virtual
machine as a resource a cloud storage
bucket as a resource but then we also
lift a little bit higher because just
managing these young division of a few
thousand VMs gets it gets a little
cumbersome so we then we have higher
level resources things like a project in
GC p is a resource and it's basically
resource container underneath the
project you have your actual resources
like VMs in storage and bakery and so on
but we also make the project itself a
resource so you can search permissions
the policies on a project level and then
they can be inherited by all the smaller
resources underneath
it cool so that sounds a little bit like
when we said like we had project editors
project owners and project readers what
what is the big difference between that
what we used to have and I am yeah so
project owner and editor and viewers the
the rows you had in the past they were
kind of I am version 0 right they were
the most basic set of permissions that
you could grant to users to be share
your project with them not a problem
that a lot of customers had was that
there now granular enough so for example
if you want to let your developers just
look at the logs in a project so they
can do debugging you have to grant them
a project viewer and by granting them a
pure project viewer they can not only
see the logs but they can also you know
read out a content of the data store and
storage bucket and if you're running a
reapplication the data in these storage
systems could be your sensitive pie
customer data so it's not really great
for all of our developers to have access
to that or another example we've heard
is a customer uses a continuous
integration system to deploy updates to
the GAE app and when they do that they
had to give the the CI system approach
it editor role but by having that role
the CI system could also go hang out
again modify other things in their
storage back here how are things in
computing networking that's not really
their intention so these roles were very
first step kind of step 0 but they were
not granular enough for anybody to
really secure the resources and that's
why we've had to do you know to push out
the real I am system with granular
control in the last few weeks cool so it
sounds like I am is particularly focused
around security are there other reasons
you might want to use it outside of
security or is that pretty much the big
reason well security is a big part of it
certainly securing your resources is the
main intention of I am but then there's
also for example if you are using
automation to access gcp if your program
matically creating VMS or manage your
storage buckets you need to let your
program access gcp and then now you have
the problem of how do i verify that this
program is the one
intending to have it access gcp so
another part of i am what we do is to
give you a feature called a service
account which is a way for you to create
a robot account so that your programs
can call gcp api interesting so that
basically means that now i could have
some bots that do something for a
specific and i could say they can only
do exactly what they're supposed to do
so if for any reason someone hacked it
or whatever they couldn't do anything
extra right yeah exactly and then that's
actually where you know using service
accounts is where we see a lot of times
people want very very granular
permissions your people might you know
do a broader job function by the service
accounts sometimes can do very specific
things you know just to manage storage
adjust manage a pub sub topic and that's
where we see permissions can get very
granular excellent so if I want to get
started with I am like how do i how do I
sort of control what resources I can
access you know if i'm a vm or like how
do i do that is it like a command-line
interface can i do it through the
website is it programmatic what sort of
tools have i got available to me so we
have support for accessing IM policies
through both you I API and see how I and
you set the IM policy on a resource we
just talked about resource could be you
know individual thing like pop subtopic
can be a project or can be above a
project like an organization so for
every resource level that supports
resource specific IM policies there is a
common meta API getting certain policy
and test permissions as well as a common
UI widget to view the permissions and
change any of the permissions so it will
look very similar but it can be done on
different resources so the other thought
I just have was around like resources so
say I have like a thousand VMs am I able
to group those together in some way I
don't want obviously be setting
permissions on each one individually I
mean maybe I could do that
programmatically but is there an easier
way yeah yeah that's a very good
question so the I talked about how we
layer the resources you know you have
your basic V games and above that is a
project and that's
after where you group the resources that
belong to a single service for example
that's a basic level of grouping and a
project isn't you know there for you to
set permission so they getting here to
the VMS it's a mechanism to group of ems
but it's also kind of the basic unit for
you to set on things like billing and
quota and a lot of the other control
mechanisms and that bar projects some
some of our customers Google itself
included as you get into car usage over
time you end up with many projects
because you've you know moved many
services sound to cloud Google itself
we've we've got more than a hundred
thousand projects and then of course
managing them individually is also going
to be cumbersome so we have introduced
this higher level resource called the
organization node and that's the root
node for your company and then other
projects that employees in your company
created will belong to the organization
node so you can kind of you can now
manage resources on the ark level on a
project level and then in some cases for
for certain resources on the individual
research level are of these levels
policies inherited down this research
hierarchy so for example if you grant
your networking team in your company the
network admin role on the organization
level that means that they have the
network happening permission now are of
the projects and all of the networks in
these projects underneath the
organization so you don't have to
permission them individually cool so I
guess that means it's great so that
means you can really sort of choose
which level it is you want to be able to
pick at you can sort of go all the way
at the top which is that sort of old
hierarchy to like say like all the way
down to VMS and just levels in between
as well yeah yeah that's correct so on
your level it's typically your you know
your company central network happening
or essential admins people who are
looking after having oversight over the
entire company's resources and on
project level we typically is about your
team rather people who are taking care
of a service together and then an
immediate research level right now we
have the support for you know a few pops
up resources and then GCS bigquery but
we can add those two things like VMs so
that's where if
you share the amount of a research level
often when you for example need to let a
particular developer debug a particular
vm or particular storage bucket for a
little bit or your [ __ ] you know sharing
a Star Trek package through an
application when you get very very
specific about a particular resource
cool so I have to ask the question I
know I users were clamoring for I am for
quite a while and it took us a while to
sort of give out the door but you at you
at we talked about this a bit before
this conversation and I think you had a
really good answer for that situation
would you like to share it I think the
question is why did it take so long yeah
pretty much well a system like I am is
is something that almost pretty much
every single one of our api's goes
through right every time you make an API
call to to gcp it does and I am chick so
when we were replacing you know the old
system to to get it to the new platform
so we can premiere more granular control
we really want to make sure that it
doesn't hurt reliability anyway right we
need to make sure that from behavior
point of view from reliability and the
agency and every perspective the new
system is at power better than the old
system before we replace it so had to be
very careful about it's like replacing
your core you know you're playing Scott
engine while flying it will in meeting
sure you're playing still stable and
doesn't drop in height so we've we've
you know how to do extensive testing and
putting a lot of infrastructure to make
sure that that switches very smooth what
we end up doing was you know we had the
old system running we had a new system
up and then while all that real traffic
was going through the old system we
sending parallel the same traffic
through the new system kind of played
the dark lunch and then through locked
when we saw that all the behaviors are
identical and the reliability latency
better that's only then did we switch
over to the new system and even after we
switched with Duke withdrew keeping the
old system up for a while as a backup
right we want to make sure that this
transition is really smooth it doesn't
hurt any of the user experience and it's
only for a better cool so I have a
question maybe the answer is is no and
then it's a feature request but so I'm
imagining a world where you actually
have just won't
project and a bunch of compute engine
instances right and what you want to say
is that someone has access to those
instances as long as the instance has a
specific tag is that something that we
provide not today right now you can you
know when you grant somebody an instance
admin role on project they get access to
all the other instances in that project
you could do a little subdividing one
thing we have shipped is per vm service
accounts so you know you could by
granting people access and the per
service account basis you could say you
know this person is allowed to speak up
V and that only of a certain identity
but we don't have we don't we don't yet
have the you know you have access to
everything there's project where only
when it's labeled X and I have heard for
a number of customers to desire to do
that we're definitely considering that
our roadmap very cool so since you're
already talking about the roadmap what
else can we expect to see in the future
so one of the first things we often get
as soon as we tell people look here the
20-something beautiful new granular rows
we have shipped is but what about this
other row I really want you know
bigquery comes have monitoring concept a
fair number of them depends on the
particular products you're using you
won't roles for yup you know the
products you care about so you can give
our very granular permissions so we're
definitely working on shipping you know
the next batch of rows based on
different services and we're also
working on giving you the ability to
make custom roles because for you know
for we hoping that in the eighty percent
case you can just make use of the out of
box roles and that's the easiest path it
saves you a lot of work but for some of
our more advanced customers they
especially in the case of for example
service accounts right they want to
tailor to very specific permission sets
so we also working on making it possible
to create your own custom roles and then
and then beyond that also we talked
about you know the ability to let you
specify permission based on labels so we
call these conditions this set of syntax
allow you to say
yes grandest person such and such a role
and such research but also only if you
know the personal research meet such set
of conditions and these could be labels
it could be you know time-based it could
be a key base oh the number of
additional policies that we're looking
at that could be added to the a.m syntax
and also of course once we allow you to
use as granular Rose do you think very
custom way the next problem you're going
to run into is that they become hard to
manage a how to debug so we definitely
also want to invest in the debugging
experience to make the policy language
not only rich but are so easy to use so
that sounds like some really interesting
features I just wanted to backtrack for
just one second because we've mentioned
it a few times we talked about service
accounts but I don't think we really
sort of talked about what those are and
what the relationships those have built
I am can you sort of explain what what
they are and how that ties directly into
I am that's a really good question so
typically when you think about one more
thing about identities they think about
users right a person who can type of
user name password or press I hardware
key but sometimes especially when you're
interacting with clouds for API there's
a lot of automation a lot of
applications people build that talk to
IEPs not necessarily from a user as a
person but rather as a program and a
program can go and typing user name
password they don't work the same way as
human beings so we we need to give these
these robots kind of an identity as well
and and that's where service accounts
came to be right we need to have a way
to manage identities for automations
either around App Engine compute engine
around somewhere else and have them
authenticate and be able to access API
is insecure as well so that's that's a
service account now seems we talk about
service accounts count type username
passwords they authenticate by a key so
when are more keys can be created for
each service account on gcp and then you
can basically use the key in your
program to let your program authenticate
with the key to to prove who they are to
access the resources well if your
program happens to run our App Engine
compute engine then your life becomes a
lot easier because we actually manage
the keys for you the keys actually
sensitive data because once you have
them they you can prove who you are in
excess resources
if you're running I went off the one of
the gcp compute platforms that we keep
the key we keep the keys for you we are
not here rotate the keys for you so you
don't have to worry about losing them or
leaking them and if you're running a
program somewhere else you can download
the keys to be using own program but
please take care of them because they
they basically open the door to your
resources excellent well I think we're
sort of running out of time just a
little bit but is there anything about I
am that you want to mention that maybe
we haven't covered yet or haven't talked
about yet so one thing I want to bring
up is in my conversation with a lot of
customers well we what we often find is
that people tend to think about when
they you know have a security incident
haha when they went when things get a
lot of little out of control but the
best way to actually plan for him is to
plan ahead before you get to the point
where you you know you go holy crap have
got a tightened down security a lot of
the planning's we'll talk about on the
research level you know how you set up
your organization how you lay out your
projects and you know what groups you
set up and some of these high-level
concepts are much easier to think about
you decided to lay out before you you go
you know you've already got an
application rounding last minute trying
to tighten up security so you know do a
little thinking ahead of time about how
you want to arrange your resources how I
wanna say a policies never help your
apps to go a long way coop that sounds
like a very good piece of advice well
thank you very much for your time rate I
learned a lot thank you i really enjoy
talking to you by IM much appreciated
thanks so much thank you thanks so much
to ray for joining us today really
appreciate having that chat i have a
much better appreciation now of identity
and access management yeah yeah very
interesting i learned a lot and i'm
actually gonna start using that next
time i have a bigger project definitely
absolutely but why are we talking about
the question of the week I think this
one's a little interesting one so we've
had cloud storage for a while you know
so if you have a static binary asset you
want to put in the cloud and have edge
caching you know all over the world
Cloud Storage has always been great for
that yeah but the question always comes
up like what if I'm dynamically creating
content like maybe images or sound files
or movie
and I want to also have that sort of
edge caching around the world how can I
do that yeah even if that images those
images are just store in some hard disk
and just have a web server serving them
how do you yeah so there's actually a
great thing that we added recently which
is what we call google cloud CDN and see
the N stands for content distribution
network yes and it's in beta and what
this is it's basically just something
that you cannot on top of any HTTP or
HTTPS load balancer and it allows you to
do exactly that cash requests the way it
works is just by the simple the
traditional HTTP HTTPS caching mechanism
so you have those headers and yeah we're
going to catch the responses to the
requests that have the method is get and
the answer is like 200 and there's a
bunch of specific week constraints to
decide if something is captured not so
just go check it out in the commutation
the interesting thing is that it is very
very easy to set up so once you have
your load balancer everything you need
to do is just click on a checkbox and
that's it you're ready to go and now you
have a you have a cash now as soon as
you have cash the next question is cool
how do I invalidate it that always
happens and it's actually very simple if
you've used memcache on App Engine where
you have a little console where you can
go and look for a key and just remove it
same thing pretty much but instead of
going to memcache you're going to go to
the load balancing page in networking
and find the caching tab and just remove
it there very easy sweet so I could set
up a vm that could have some sort of job
that it serves out assets may be
dynamically maybe generates them
something like that and then just put an
HTTPS load balancer on it and you know
I'm good to go yeah so uh as a test of
what I did is I just had a bunch of a
bunch of machines in an instance group
and i created a load balancer on top of
that all of them were running engine XO
that's it and it works very well also it
could be really easy to do if you're
running on g/km come on container engine
because when you create a surface and
you said that the service type is load
balancer it will actually create a
little banister so you just go there and
click on start cashing and that's it
ready to go nice trick I like it yeah
very cool excellent so before we go I
totally want to mention a couple of
interesting new developments most
recently we we as in Google have
announced that podcasts are available on
google play music yeah so you can now
get the Google cloud platform podcast on
google play music as well if you go to
our website check the subscribe button
or the About section you'll see that
we're available there yep which is
pretty exciting and on top of that I
think that you can now find out there
and also you can now subscribe to our
mailing list yeah so we have an email
subscription option if that was
something you were looking for we had a
few requests for it so yeah now you can
go there put in your email address and
we'll send you an email whenever a new
episode comes out and since we're
already there whether we remind
everybody all of our listeners how to
get in touch with us definitely so if I
email let's hello at JCP podcast com I'm
gonna start with the one I always forget
which is slack we have a podcast channel
on the Google Cloud communities black
community yes yes absolutely and
actually I little just updated our About
section 2 so if you're looking for a
little bit more information about how to
get on that slight community that's all
in the About section on our website
twitter is gcp podcast google+ is plus
just podcast reddit is / are gcp podcast
and that's it we're done and that's it
ok it's ok no actually the webpage is
Jesus book has become you did not
mention there we go there you go so yeah
cool so where are we going to find you
next week next week I and I'm taking a
little trip down to Kentucky i will be
at vector comp and then also hitting up
the louisville GDG talking to them about
some communities and talking a vector
come about how cloud can change your
game very cool and yourself I'm gonna
have a slightly longer trip I'm going to
Budapest in hand
for craft conf very very excited about
that so if you're wrong come too high
excellent well Francis thank you so much
for joining me yet again this week thank
you again for joining me mark and dr.
neck sick see you next week
you